fans of Vanessa Hudgens are excited to
see her perform and foxes live TV
musical wrench later this month
but as kelsey found out while there was
a slight bump on her road to rent
actually on my way to this audition I
was coming from another audition and my
car nice hire pop and I got into my uber
car and it's like okay I'm really sorry
but I'm going to this audition where I'm
singing do you care if I give you the CD
and I do
cormaneau compact disc I know it's easy
just pop it in the car call me old
school and I'm like me me me me
that uber prep worked Vanessa snagged
the lead role of marine and foxes live
production of rent and when the show
airs on January to 27th keep an eye out
for this guy
Brennan hunt a former X Factor
contestant turned a Nashville
singer-songwriter could be a scene
stealer as Roger how do you prepare for
a live moment this is what I do right
here and playing the iconic role of
Angel is Valentina
a fan favorite from RuPaul's Drag Race
have you heard from Mamoru about this
not yet
you're a very busy I'm pretty sure that
they are sorry I'm sending you flowers
to my trailer girl I have a trailer I
know crazy crazy like backstage at a
drag show - like your own trailer I know
there's another janky bar this is like
legit Hollywood Life Cathy looks happy
this is her all-time favorite show and
once again rent airs live on Fox January
27th if you forget Kelsey will remind
[Music]
[Applause]